OK, I don't know exactly what this says about Australia, but when you win this big literary prize they have there, the Melbourne Prize for Literature, you're required to spend half the money, half of it, to get out of Melbourne and travel abroad. Which is sort of weird, right? Like they're saying simultaneously, let's celebrate the culture of Melbourne, and then they're giving you the money to escape it.
好吧，我不知道这对澳大利亚意味着什么，但在那里获得著名的文学奖——墨尔本文学奖时，你必须把奖金的一半，也就是一半，花在离开墨尔本去国外旅行上。这听起来有点奇怪，对吧？就像他们一方面在庆祝墨尔本的文化，另一方面又给你钱让你逃离这里。
A few years ago when this great Australian novelist named Gerald Murnane learned that he was nominated, he asked that his name be withdrawn from consideration.
几年前，当伟大的澳大利亚小说家杰拉德·莫南得知自己被提名时，他要求撤回对他的提名。
Because there was no way he was going to leave the country.
因为他绝不可能离开这个国家。
This is Helen Garner, an Australian who's won this prize herself, and who wrote about what happened when they wanted to give it to Murnane.
这位是海伦·加纳，一位曾获得过该奖项的澳大利亚作家，她记录了当组委会想要把奖颁给莫南时发生的事情。
He's noted for the fact that he doesn't like to travel. I don't think he's ever been outside Australia. And he makes a point of saying that he's never going to leave this country. He's never wanted to, and he thinks that everything one needs to know could be known just as well here as anywhere else in the world.
他以不喜欢旅行而闻名。我想他从来没有去过澳大利亚以外的地方。他明确表示自己永远不会离开这个国家。他从未有过这样的想法，而且他认为，世界上任何地方能了解到的知识，在这里也同样可以了解。
But he's this deeply original writer, and the committee decided to bend the rules for him. Helen was in the auditorium when he received the award.
但他是一位非常有独创性的作家，委员会决定为他破例。海伦在他领奖时就在礼堂里。
And he was obviously in his rather inward introverted sort of way terribly happy to have won the prize. And he explained to the audience his stand on international travel.
他显然以他那种内向、沉静的方式，对获得这个奖感到非常高兴。他向观众解释了他对国际旅行的立场。
But he said, in the spirit of the prize, he would do something else. He would use some of the prize money to fill his car with gas and drive around to some of the places that he had lived in and around Melbourne.
但他表示，本着该奖项的精神，他会做点别的。他会用一部分奖金给自己的车加满油，然后开车去他在墨尔本及其周边住过的一些地方看看。
And that was when the speech became really wonderful, because he just kind of tilted his head back and closed his eyes and reeled off this list of addresses, his former addresses in the suburbs of Melbourne. And they were very undistinguished parts of town. They're the very obscure suburbs that nobody ever talks about and nothing dramatic ever seems to happen there.
就在那时，这段演讲变得非常精彩，因为他只是向后仰起头，闭上眼睛，如数家珍般列出了一串地址，他以前在墨尔本郊区的住所。那些都是非常普通的地方。那是些没人谈论、似乎从未发生过任何戏剧性事件的无名郊区。
And he reeled them off like somebody chanting or praying by heart. He had them all by heart in chronological order.
他背诵这些地名时，就像在吟诵或祈祷一样。他凭记忆按时间顺序把它们全记住了。
Yes, all right. We would say The Avenue, Coburg; Breese Street, Brunswick; Plenty Road, Bundoora.
是的，没错。我们会说：位于科堡的Avenue街，位于不伦瑞克的Breese街，位于邦杜拉的Plenty路。
There's no recording of this speech, but when I phoned Gerald Murnane at his home, he was able to recite for me all 20 locations from memory in the order that he lived in them.
这段演讲没有录音，但当我给杰拉德·莫南的家里打电话时，他凭记忆向我背出了他住过的所有20个地点，顺序分毫不差。
And the end of the list is Ray Street, Pascoe Vale; Bakers Road, North Coburg; Peter Street, South Oakleigh; and then Legon Road, South Oakley; and then Filbert Street, South Caulfied.
名单的结尾是帕斯科谷的Ray街，北科堡的Bakers路，南奥克利的Peter街，然后是南奥克利的Legon路，接着是南考菲尔德的Filbert街。
What we knew was that he was really reciting a kind of a poem of such modestly named places that had such meaning to him.
我们知道，他实际上是在朗诵一首诗，关于那些对他意义非凡、名字平庸的地方。
Gweno Avenue, Frankston; Fitzroy Street in Kilda; River Street, South Yarra.
弗兰克斯顿的Gweno大道，圣基尔达的Fitzroy街，南亚拉的River街。
And there was something so wonderful about it. And then when he finished and opened his eyes and looked around, the whole place just went up in a roar where everyone was delighted, and half laughing, and half tearful. It was very moving and wonderful. I'm terribly glad that I was there.
这一切太美妙了。当他结束演讲，睁开眼睛环顾四周时，全场爆发出热烈的掌声，每个人都欣喜若狂，半是欢笑，半是泪水。那场面非常动人，太棒了。我非常庆幸我当时在场。
Gerald Murnane told me even he was moved by it.
杰拉德·莫南告诉我，连他自己也被感动了。
Place and locality and these things, they do matter much to me. I've got this sort of mental geography. In a way, it's probably been bred into me by the fact that I move so often. We moved almost every year because my father was a gambler on race horses and also a reckless man who was always looking for-- he just couldn't sit in one place. We lived at all these different addresses.
地点、方位，这些东西对我来说真的很重要。我有一种精神地理学。在某种程度上，这可能源于我频繁搬家。我们几乎每年都搬家，因为我父亲是个赌马的赌徒，也是个鲁莽的人，总是寻找……他就是坐不住。我们住在所有这些不同的地址。
(INTERVIEW) IRA GLASS: When you list them off like that, is the feeling nostalgia, or is it even stronger? Is it a feeling of like, this is me, that in some way you're describing yourself?
（采访）艾拉·格拉斯：当你像那样列举它们时，那是一种怀旧的感觉，还是更强烈的感觉？那是一种“这就是我”的感觉吗，你在某种程度上是在描述你自己？
You nearly got it right, then-- I feel a sense of pride-- I'm not boasting, but I feel a sense of pride that I survived all that. I mean, when I say survive, we were quite poor.
你说得差不多了——我感到一种自豪——我不是在吹嘘，但我感到一种自豪，因为我从那一切中生存了下来。我是说，当我说生存时，我们当时真的很穷。
(INTERVIEW) IRA GLASS: I grew up in the suburbs of Baltimore, which is a city not far from Washington, DC.
（采访）艾拉·格拉斯：我在巴尔的摩郊区长大，那是一座离华盛顿特区不远的城市。
Baltimore, Maryland.
马里兰州巴尔的摩。
(INTERVIEW) IRA GLASS: Yeah, yeah. Baltimore, Maryland. And when I look back on it, I feel like I understand that it shaped me in certain ways. But I also feel like this is just a random place that happened to be the place that I grew up. Like, there's nothing special about it. I feel no attachment to it. I have no sentimental feelings about the place. And is your attachment to these places now that they seem special in some way, or are they simply familiar?
（采访）艾拉·格拉斯：是的，是的。马里兰州巴尔的摩。当我回顾往事时，我觉得我明白它在某些方面塑造了我。但我也觉得这只是一个随机的地方，恰好是我长大的地方。它没什么特别的。我对其没有任何依恋。我对它没有感伤的情绪。你现在对这些地方的依恋是因为它们在某种程度上很特别，还是仅仅因为熟悉？
Well, they certainly don't feel special, and I've said already that I don't go back to visit them. I'm not attached to these places. They attached themselves to me in a sense. And I don't want to go back there. I don't want to be the person I was then. But I do want to remember them. I can't put it any better than that.
嗯，它们当然感觉不特别，我已经说过我不会回去看它们。我并不依恋这些地方。在某种意义上，是它们依恋着我。我不想回到那里。我不想成为当时的那个我。但我确实想记住它们。我无法用更好的语言来表达了。
(INTERVIEW) IRA GLASS: Why?
（采访）艾拉·格拉斯：为什么？
Remember them, because they made me. The combination of all the strange experiences that I had, or lack of experience, or yearnings, or unfulfilled wants, they made me.
记住它们，因为它们造就了我。我所有的奇怪经历、缺乏经验、渴望或未满足的需求的结合，造就了我。
Well, today on our program, we don't choose where we grow up. We don't choose the family we're born into. And when we head out into the bigger world, that's the private geography we carry with us. Today, we have two stories where we see what that geography reveals about two very different people. One of them, current Secretary of Education, Betsy DeVos. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
好了，今天在我们的节目中，我们无法选择在哪里长大。我们无法选择出生的家庭。当我们走向广阔的世界时，那就是我们随身携带的私人地理。今天，我们有两个故事，看看这些地理位置如何揭示了两个截然不同的人。其中之一是现任教育部长贝特西·德沃斯。来自芝加哥WBEZ，这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
Act one, Vouching towards Bethlehem. So the issue that our Secretary of Education, Betsy DeVos, has fought hardest for over the years, the issue that she hopes to engage as education secretary, is school choice in all of its forms.
第一幕，通往伯利恒的代金券。所以，我们的教育部长贝特西·德沃斯多年来最力争的问题，她希望作为教育部长着手解决的问题，就是各种形式的择校。
One of those forms? School choice means fostering a system of charter schools as alternatives to the regular public school system. These schools are supposed to be laboratories of great teaching, places where some of the rules and regulations of regular public schools don't apply. School choice also means vouchers, which, of course, lets parents pull their kids out of public schools, and put them into parochial schools, or church schools, or private schools of all kinds. And state money that had gone to the public schools would follow the children with a voucher to the private schools they enroll in.
其中一种形式是什么？择校意味着培育特许学校体系，作为常规公立学校体系的替代方案。这些学校应该是优秀教学的实验室，在这里，常规公立学校的一些规章制度不适用。择校也意味着代金券，当然，这让家长可以把孩子从公立学校拉出来，送到教区学校、教会学校或各种私立学校。原本拨给公立学校的国家资金会随着代金券跟随着孩子进入他们入学的私立学校。
DeVos says her interest in all this started when her son was entering Kindergarten. She realized that she had the means to send him to any school she wanted to. She had a lot of money. Why shouldn't every parent be able to do that?
德沃斯说，她对这一切的兴趣始于她儿子上幼儿园时。她意识到她有财力送他去任何她想去的学校。她很有钱。为什么不是每个家长都能做到这一点呢？
So we decided at that time to help some other kids have the same opportunity as our children. We started work with that school, and then more broadly in our community funding scholarships, and realized very quickly that while we were helping individual children, which was important, it wasn't an effort that was particularly scalable. So I really decided to get involved in public policy, which I thought was going to make the most difference.
所以当时我们决定帮助其他一些孩子获得和我们孩子一样的机会。我们开始与那所学校合作，然后更广泛地在我们的社区资助奖学金，并很快意识到，虽然我们是在帮助个别孩子，这很重要，但这不是一种特别可扩展的努力。所以我真的决定参与公共政策，我认为这会产生最大的不同。
Betsy DeVos made it into the President's cabinet with as low a vote as you can get and still squeak by. It was the first time in U.S. history that the Vice President has had to cast a tie-breaking vote to confirm a cabinet secretary.
贝特西·德沃斯进入总统内阁的票数之低，几乎是勉强通过。这是美国历史上第一次由副总统投出决定性的一票来确认内阁部长。
She'd been an education advocate for decades, pushing for choice and vouchers in Michigan, where she's from. Her critics said she was a know-nothing, just some rich Republican donor with no qualifications for the job of education secretary, and specifically, no experience in the public schools. That was the rap against her. One of our producers, Susan Burton, grew up in the same home town as Betsy DeVos, Grand Rapids, Michigan, and has been aware of the DeVos family since she was a little kid. There are certain things you can learn about Betsy DeVos and her agenda by going to Grand Rapids. Here's Susan.
几十年来，她一直是教育倡导者，在她的家乡密歇根州推动择校和代金券。她的批评者说她一无所知，只是一个没有资格担任教育部长职位的富有共和党捐款人，特别是没有公立学校的经验。这就是对她的指控。我们的一位制片人苏珊·伯顿在贝特西·德沃斯的家乡密歇根州大急流城长大，从小就知道德沃斯家族。通过前往大急流城，你可以了解到关于贝特西·德沃斯和她的议程的某些事情。这是苏珊。
One of the things you'd hear over and over in the weeks leading up to Betsy DeVos's confirmation hearings was that she'd never set foot in a public school. It was often phrased exactly this way. People said it to news reporters, repeated it in speeches.
在贝特西·德沃斯确认听证会之前的几周里，你听到最多的一件事就是她从未踏入过公立学校。它通常就是这样表达的。人们对新闻记者这样说，在演讲中重复。
Betsy DeVos has never set foot in a public school.
贝特西·德沃斯从未踏入过公立学校。
This woman has never stepped foot in a public school.
这个女人从未踏入过公立学校。
He nominated a woman who had never worked in, volunteered in, ever stepped foot in a public school until he chose her to be his Secretary of Education.
他提名了一个从未在公立学校工作过、志愿服务过、从未踏入过公立学校的女人，直到他选择她成为他的教育部长。
That's the head of one of the two national teachers unions. But when I talked to people in Grand Rapids, I heard a different story, that she had spent time in a public school, volunteering as a mentor. At first, nobody could give me details. It was all rumors and secondhand information. Here's Elizabeth Welch, a local public school advocate.
那是全国两个教师工会之一的负责人。但当我与大急流城的人交谈时，我听到了不同的故事，她曾在公立学校呆过，志愿担任导师。起初，没有人能给我细节。这都是谣言和二手信息。这是当地公立学校倡导者伊丽莎白·韦尔奇。
In just community conversations with people, we knew she hadn't been deeply involved in Grand Rapids Public. And so, I was through a few discussions where it was through the grapevine I had heard, oh, I heard she tutored some kids at Burton Elementary.
在与人们的日常对话中，我们知道她没有深入参与大急流城的公立学校。所以，我经历了几次讨论，通过小道消息听说，哦，我听说她在伯顿小学辅导过一些孩子。
Well, I had heard that she had said she had done that kind of stuff. But I didn't know where.
嗯，我听说她说过她做过那种事。但我不知道在哪里。
This is Mary Bouwense, the head of the local teacher's union.
这是当地教师工会负责人玛丽·鲍文斯。
Because when she said I tutored in Grand Rapids, well, she could have been tutoring at one of the Christian elementaries. You know, it could have been in the area of Grand Rapids, 'cause sometimes people say Grand Rapids, but they mean Kentwood, or Wyoming, or one of the suburbs too. They just say Grand Rapids as a general term. So I just assumed it was going to be the Christian schools that she tutored in when she showed up, because a lot of their money goes into those buildings. So.
因为当她说我在大急流城辅导时，嗯，她可能是在其中一所基督教小学辅导。你知道，这可能是在大急流城地区，因为有时人们说大急流城，但他们的意思也是肯特伍德、怀俄明州或其中一个郊区。他们只是把大急流城作为一个通用术语。所以我只是认为她辅导的是基督教学校，因为他们很多钱都投入到了那些建筑中。所以。
I'm from Grand Rapids, so I knew what Mary was talking about, the schools associated with the Christian Reformed Church. I have friends who went to these schools. My next door neighbor, Jason, went to Ada Christian. So did Jenny from swim team. Nicole from acting went to Seymour Christian. Betsy DeVos went to these schools, and also sent her own four children there.
我来自大急流城，所以我知道玛丽在说什么，与基督教改革宗有关的学校。我有朋友去过这些学校。我的邻居杰森去了Ada Christian。游泳队的珍妮也是。表演班的妮可去了Seymour Christian。贝特西·德沃斯去了这些学校，也把她自己的四个孩子送到了那里。
The Christian Reformed Church has its own history of school choice. Back in the 1850s, a group of Dutch settlers in West Michigan split off from their church to form their own denomination. And one of the big reasons-- they didn't want their children in public schools. They wanted their children to be formed in the faith, in their own schools, before sending them out into the world.
基督教改革宗有自己的择校历史。早在19世纪50年代，一群荷兰定居者在西密歇根州从他们的教会中分离出来，形成了他们自己的教派。主要原因之一是——他们不希望他们的孩子在公立学校。他们希望他们的孩子在送入世界之前，在他们自己的学校中接受信仰的熏陶。
The idea that parents of all backgrounds should be able to choose a school reflecting their values and beliefs, that's part of the theological history of the CRC. At first, I had a hard time finding people to talk about Betsy DeVos and the public school she volunteered in, partly because the DeVoses are such a prominent family in Grand Rapids. They're major philanthropists. Lots of buildings have the DeVos name on them.
所有背景的家长都应该能够选择一所反映他们价值观和信仰的学校的理念，这是CRC神学历史的一部分。起初，我很难找到人来谈论贝特西·德沃斯和她志愿服务的公立学校，部分原因是德沃斯家族在大急流城是一个非常显赫的家族。他们是主要的慈善家。很多建筑上都有德沃斯的名字。
At age 10, I performed "It's a Hard Knock Life" from Annie with seven other girls on the stage in DeVos Hall, which is inside DeVos Place, which isn't so far from the Helen DeVos Children's Hospital, the Richard M. DeVos Center, and a bit further out, the DeVos Center for Arts and Worship at Grand Rapids Christian High School.
10岁时，我和其他七个女孩在德沃斯大厅的舞台上表演了《安妮》中的“It's a Hard Knock Life”，该厅位于德沃斯广场内，距离海伦·德沃斯儿童医院、理查德·M·德沃斯中心不远，再远一点是大急流城基督教高中的德沃斯艺术与礼拜中心。
The DeVos fortune comes from Amway. When I was a little girl, I wasn't exactly sure what Amway did. Sold stuff in a weird way, not in stores. Betsy DeVos married the eldest son of Amway's founder, but she's also from an iconic local family. Her father, Edgar Prince, made his millions in West Michigan as an auto parts manufacturer. One of his inventions? The light up mirror visor.
德沃斯家族的财富来自安利。当我还是个小女孩时，我不确定安利是做什么的。以奇怪的方式卖东西，而不是在商店里。贝特西·德沃斯嫁给了安利创始人的长子，但她也来自一个标志性的当地家庭。她的父亲埃德加·普林斯作为汽车零部件制造商在西密歇根州赚了数百万。他的发明之一？带灯的镜子遮阳板。
I finally did reach someone who'd been at the public school Betsy DeVos volunteered at, Burton Elementary. I'm Susan Burton, but that's not my family's name on the building, by the way. The woman I reached, I'll call her Denise.
我终于联系到了一个在贝特西·德沃斯志愿服务的公立学校伯顿小学工作过的人。我是苏珊·伯顿，顺便说一句，那不是我家在建筑上的名字。我联系到的那个女人，我会叫她丹妮丝。
A lot of teachers were like, she's never been in one of our schools. And I said, well, no, she has. I've seen her. What? You know, they couldn't believe that she even set foot in a public school, and in a Grand Rapids public school. They could not believe it. Yeah, they were shocked.
很多老师说，她从来没有进过我们的学校。我说，不，她进过。我见过她。什么？你知道，他们不敢相信她竟然踏入过公立学校，而且是一所大急流城的公立学校。他们无法相信。是的，他们很震惊。
Denise used to be a teacher at Burton, the Grand Rapids public school where it turns out Betsy DeVos volunteered for five years. As far as I can tell, it's the most sustained encounter with a public school that she's ever had, and Betsy DeVos says it affected her deeply.
丹妮丝曾经是伯顿的老师，这是贝特西·德沃斯志愿服务五年的大急流城公立学校。据我所知，这是她有过的与公立学校最持续的接触，贝特西·德沃斯说这深深地影响了她。
She didn't respond to any of the questions or interview requests I sent to the Department of Education, but she did talk briefly about the experience at her confirmation hearing in January.
她没有回答我发送给教育部的问题或采访请求，但她在1月份的确认听证会上简短地谈到了这一经历。
I've worked as an in-school mentor for students in the Grand Rapids Public Schools, and have had the privilege of interacting with students and their families and teachers in ways that have changed my life and my perspective about education forever.
我曾在大急流城公立学校担任学生的校内导师，有幸以改变我一生和对教育观点的方式与学生及其家人和老师互动。
Here's how Betsy DeVos wound up at Burton Elementary back in 2003. She was not a random parent walking in to help out. She was one of the most powerful educational activists in the state, a major Republican donor. Since the early '90s, she'd been advocating for increased choice in Michigan schools.
这是贝特西·德沃斯回到2003年如何来到伯顿小学的经过。她不是一个随机走进来帮忙的家长。她是州里最有权势的教育活动家之一，是主要的共和党捐款人。自90年代初以来，她一直在密歇根州倡导增加择校。
In 1993, she helped the governor make Michigan one of the first states in the nation to allow charter schools. In 2000, she introduced a ballot measure to get vouchers in the state. At the time, she was the chair of the state Republican Party. The governor didn't support her measure, so she quit. It was that important to her.
1993年，她帮助州长使密歇根州成为全国首批允许特许学校的州之一。2000年，她提出了在州内获得代金券的投票措施。当时，她是州共和党主席。州长不支持她的措施，所以她辞职了。这对她来说非常重要。
She and her husband spent more than $2 million of their own money to promote the measure. The campaign flew people to see voucher schools in Milwaukee on a private Amway jet. When voters rejected the measure, she spent even more to influence legislators. She started lobbying groups at the state and national level.
她和丈夫花费了超过200万美元的个人资金来推广这项措施。竞选活动用安利的私人飞机将人们送到密尔沃基观看代金券学校。当选民拒绝该措施时，她又花费了更多资金来影响立法者。她开始在州和国家层面建立游说团体。
Her former lobbying director told me that when somebody challenged her about what she was going to do to make local public schools better, she signed up to mentor students. She did this through a group called Kids Hope USA. It's a national organization that pairs churches with public schools. She was in the first group of mentors from her church.
她以前的游说主管告诉我，当有人挑战她打算如何使当地公立学校变得更好时，她报名担任了学生导师。她是通过一个叫Kids Hope USA的团体做到这一点的。这是一个将教会与公立学校配对的全国性组织。她是她教会第一批导师中的一员。
Sharon Olette was in charge of the Kids Hope USA program at their church for years. She says they knew the kind of school they wanted to partner with and set out to find it.
莎伦·奥莱特多年来一直负责他们教会的Kids Hope USA项目。她说他们知道他们想与之合作的学校类型，并着手寻找它。
I mean, we're a very Caucasian, white America church and didn't have the opportunity to interact with inner city kids and the Hispanic community like we wanted to. And this was such a wonderful avenue for us to do that, to really live out our faith.
我是说，我们是一个非常高加索人的、白人美国的教会，没有机会像我们想要的那样与内城孩子和西班牙裔社区互动。这对于我们来说是一个非常美妙的途径，真正活出我们的信仰。
And one of the pastors at the time just drove around the inner city and looked at the different schools and was kind of praying over all of that situation, what school we should partner with. And he had actually another school in mind, and he happened to go by Burton Elementary, and he said it was just clear to him that God was saying this is the one. This is the school. So that's kind of an exciting story.
当时的牧师之一只是开车在内城周围，看着不同的学校，并为所有这些情况祈祷，我们应该与哪所学校合作。他实际上想到了另一所学校，他碰巧经过伯顿小学，他说对他来说很清楚上帝在说这就是那个。这就是学校。所以这是一个令人兴奋的故事。
The volunteer mentors were not teaching religion. They were just there to mentor the kids, every week for one hour. The kids at Burton are mostly Latino, speak Spanish as a first language, and they're almost all poor. Denise, the former teacher, was proud of the work she did that. The school had a great principal, and Denise felt like she was part of a dedicated staff, a group giving it's all, trying to help these students with the limited resources they had. Into that walks Betsy DeVos.
志愿导师不是在教宗教。他们只是在那里每周一小时辅导孩子。伯顿的孩子大多是拉丁裔，以西班牙语为第一语言，而且他们几乎都很穷。前老师丹妮丝为她所做的工作感到自豪。学校有一位很棒的校长，丹妮丝觉得她是忠诚员工的一部分，一个全力以赴的团队，试图用他们有限的资源来帮助这些学生。贝特西·德沃斯走进了那个环境。
And then I still remember the first time I ever saw her walking down the hallway in a really, really just old school. Burton Elementary's a really old school, and just drinking fountains that didn't work, and the bathrooms that didn't have soap. And there she was in her $1,000 suit and her really pretty shoes. And I just thought how odd she looked. She just looked so out of place.
然后我仍然记得我第一次看到她走在走廊里，在非常、非常老派的学校里。伯顿小学是一所非常古老的学校，饮水机不能用，浴室里没有肥皂。她穿着1000美元的西装和非常漂亮的鞋子。我只是觉得她看起来多奇怪。她看起来太格格不入。
She had this beautiful like, tan camel hair jacket. And just the visual of her walking through and looking at everything. And I remember the story being told of that her husband would drop her off because she didn't want to park her car in the parking lot.
她穿着那种漂亮的骆驼毛夹克。她走过并看着一切的画面。我记得有人说她的丈夫会送她去，因为她不想把车停在停车场。
Like, were the cars at risk of being broken into? Was that the idea, that--
就像，车有被闯入的风险吗？那是那种想法吗，那——
I don't know. I really don't know what was running through her head.
我不知道。我真的不知道她脑子里在想什么。
Three other people who worked at Burton in those years told me Betsy DeVos had a driver who'd drop her off. One said he'd park a big black SUV up on the sidewalk near the school's front door and wait there until she came out.
那几年在伯顿工作的另外三个人告诉我，贝特西·德沃斯有一个司机送她。一个人说他会把一辆黑色大SUV停在学校前门附近的人行道上，一直等到她出来。
Betsy DeVos was assigned to mentor a little girl in third grade. She was a girl who needed extra attention in the classroom, and outside school, her housing situation was unstable. Again, Denise.
贝特西·德沃斯被分配辅导一名三年级的小女孩。她是一个在课堂上需要额外关注的女孩，在校外，她的住房情况不稳定。再次，丹妮丝。
You know, her living situation was really difficult. Many times, she just came to school hungry. She came to school tired. It was a sad situation.
你知道，她的生活状况真的很困难。很多次，她来学校时都饿着肚子。她来学校时很累。那是一个悲伤的情况。
Denise says when Betsy DeVos came to school, with the teachers, she was cordial, but not overly friendly. Denise was wary of her. But I talked to a counselor at the school, a social worker I'll call Megan who knew the little girl, and interacted with her, and who appreciated what Betsy DeVos was trying to do.
丹妮丝说，当贝特西·德沃斯来学校时，对老师很客气，但并不特别友好。丹妮丝对她保持警惕。但我与学校的一位顾问谈过，一位社会工作者，我叫她梅根，她认识那个小女孩，并与她互动，她很欣赏贝特西·德沃斯所做的一切。
I thought it was great that she was taking an interest in our lower income school. So I remember the student telling me, Miss Betsy was here this week, and just feeling special because another adult took interest in her.
我觉得她对我们低收入学校产生兴趣真是太好了。所以我记得学生告诉我，贝丝小姐这周来了，因为另一个成年人对她感兴趣，感觉很特别。
The little girl would talk to Megan about the mentoring. The attention pleased her, made her proud. And then one day, the little girl had some other news to share about Betsy DeVos.
小女孩会和梅根谈论辅导的事。这种关注让她感到高兴，让她感到骄傲。有一天，小女孩有其他关于贝特西·德沃斯的消息要分享。
The student told me that she purchased a car for her mom. Her mom was having a hard time getting to her employer. And so to keep that momentum going with her employment, I know she purchased a car and did other things for the family beyond the school.
学生告诉我，她为她的妈妈买了一辆车。她的妈妈很难到达她的雇主那里。为了保持她的就业势头，我知道她买了一辆车，并为这个家庭做了学校之外的其他事情。
Four different people at the school told me about the car. One said it came up at a staff meeting. Teachers thought it was great news for the family, but they also struggled with what to make of this kind of generosity, and whether buying the mother a car was setting her up for failure or success. Sharon, the church coordinator, heard about the car and understood the impulse.
学校里有四个人告诉我那辆车的事。一个人说它在员工会议上被提出来了。老师们认为这对家庭来说是个好消息，但他们也努力弄清楚这种慷慨意味着什么，以及为母亲买车是让她走向失败还是成功。教会协调员莎伦听说了这件事，理解这种冲动。
We all come to care for our mentees and do things to help the family in need, bringing them Thanksgiving dinner or something like that.
我们所有人都关心我们的受辅导者，并做一些事情来帮助有需要的家庭，给他们带来感恩节晚餐之类的东西。
Sharon remembered that one mentor, her husband was a dentist, and he fixed a mother's badly decayed teeth for free. This kind of stuff wasn't part of the Kids Hope USA mission. Sharon describes it as above and beyond the scope of the program. But lots of mentors developed relationships with students and families. Lots of them wanted to do more. Betsy DeVos just happens to be a billionaire, and her more is different.
莎伦记得有一位导师，她的丈夫是一名牙医，他免费修补了一位母亲严重腐烂的牙齿。这类事情不是Kids Hope USA使命的一部分。莎伦将其描述为超出项目范围。但很多导师与学生和家庭建立了关系。他们很多人想做更多。贝特西·德沃斯恰好是一位亿万富翁，她的更多是不同的。
And then Betsy DeVos gave the student another gift, one that shows her generosity and also reveals a lot about her beliefs and assumptions when it comes to educating children.
然后贝特西·德沃斯给了学生另一份礼物，一份显示了她的慷慨，也揭示了很多关于她在教育孩子方面的信念和假设。
Burton is a K-5 program, so when the student got to be at sixth grade, she put her and paid for a private school, for her to go into a private school.
伯顿是一个K-5项目，所以当学生升到六年级时，她把她送进了一所私立学校，并支付了费用。
I couldn't confirm this directly with Betsy DeVos, but five people at Burton and a close friend of Betsy DeVos's said they heard this. The way school funding works, when a child leaves a school, the school loses the funding for that child. School choice advocates say this encourages competition and innovation. Schools have to compete to attract children and the dollars that go with them. It's the free market applied to education.
我无法直接向贝特西·德沃斯证实这一点，但伯顿的五个人和贝特西·德沃斯的一位亲密朋友说他们听说了。学校资金运作的方式是，当孩子离开学校时，学校会失去该孩子的资金。择校倡导者说这鼓励竞争和创新。学校必须竞争以吸引孩子和伴随他们的美元。这是应用于教育的自由市场。
What makes this complicated is that this money pays not just for that individual child, but for salaries, and programs, and infrastructure, for all the costs of keeping the school open. Losing that money has ripple effects. And at Burton Elementary, when teachers saw one of the state's most powerful education activists, someone widely seen as anti-public school, pull a child out of the public school system, it did not go over very well with everyone. Again, here's Denise, the teacher.
复杂的是，这笔钱不仅支付给那个孩子，而且支付给工资、项目和基础设施，支付给维持学校开放的所有成本。失去那笔钱会产生连锁反应。在伯顿小学，当老师看到州里最有权势的教育活动家之一，一个被广泛认为反公立学校的人，把一个孩子从公立学校体系中拉出来时，这对每个人来说都不好过。再次，老师丹妮丝。
It's super insulting. It's very insulting. Like, what you do-- all the hard work that you put in-- is not good enough for me, or for people I know, or for people in general. It's just not good enough. And I find it rather ironic that she would tutor a student and then take her out of the school that she was working in. I thought she wanted to make the school better. She could have used her power way differently.
这超级侮辱人。非常侮辱人。就像，你所做的一切——你付出的所有辛勤工作——对我，或我认识的人，或一般人来说都不够好。这只是不够好。我觉得讽刺的是，她辅导了一个学生，然后把她从她工作的学校里拉了出来。我以为她想让学校变得更好。她本可以以完全不同的方式使用她的权力。
Instead of helping fix the school, Betsy DeVos paid to place the child elsewhere. That was her solution. It was like vouchers for one. Megan, the school social worker, says there are lots of things Betsy DeVos could have done.
而不是帮助修复学校，贝特西·德沃斯付钱把孩子安置在其他地方。那是她的解决方案。这就像给一个人用的代金券。学校社会工作者梅根说贝特西·德沃斯本可以做很多事情。
So, I mean, there were so many great things going on at Burton Elementary. I mean, there really were. We had ESL classes for the parents. We had a parent leadership group that would meet once a month and hear kind of what's going on in the community. And so I really feel like, even talking to the building leadership about trends, or what's keeping our students from reaching those academic milestones that we need them to, and really tapping into the pulse of the school and the community, I feel like there could have been a lot more there.
所以，我的意思是，伯顿小学发生了很多伟大的事情。我的意思是，确实有。我们有家长的ESL课程。我们有一个家长领导小组，每月开会一次，了解社区里正在发生的事情。所以我真的觉得，即使是与建筑领导谈论趋势，或者是什么在阻碍我们的学生达到我们需要他们达到的学术里程碑，并真正挖掘学校和社区的脉搏，我觉得那里本可以有更多。
Does this story of what happened at Burton connect to any of the concerns you have about her appointment as Education Secretary?
伯顿发生的事情的故事与你对她被任命为教育部长的担忧有联系吗？
Yeah, I mean, I think it kind of illustrates that while she may have supported individual children or causes that were in line with her values, I don't think overall she saw the big picture. So while I see there was some great generous acts, it wasn't directly supporting the school building or district.
是的，我的意思是，我认为这在某种程度上说明了，虽然她可能支持符合她价值观的个人孩子或事业，但我认为总体而言，她没有看到大局。所以虽然我看到了一些伟大的慷慨行为，但它并没有直接支持校舍或学区。
Helping individual children, but not supporting the school district as a whole. This is consistent with what Elizabeth Welch, the public school advocate in Grand Rapids, has observed of Betsy DeVos's policy agenda in Michigan.
帮助个别孩子，但不支持整个学区。这与大急流城的公立学校倡导者伊丽莎白·韦尔奇观察到的贝特西·德沃斯在密歇根州的政策议程一致。
I actually am probably not as cynical as some, in that I believe she probably really does believe the agenda is going to help kids. The problem is, as someone for 20 years who has been living here and watching the agenda be implemented, I see it as more about helping that one person.
我可能不像一些人那么愤世嫉俗，因为我相信她可能真的相信这个议程会帮助孩子。问题是，作为一个在这里生活了20年并看着议程被实施的人，我看到它更多的是关于帮助那一个人。
Take the West Michigan Aviation Academy, which is a charter school founded by the DeVoses. They've given more than $4 million to it. It's out at the airport, and kids learn how to fly planes, go up in the sky in little Cessnas.
看看西密歇根航空学院，这是一所由德沃斯家族创办的特许学校。他们已经给它捐了超过400万美元。它在机场，孩子们学习如何驾驶飞机，在小塞斯纳飞机中升空。
Wonderful school. I have friends who send their children there. Aviation's your background, your kid's kind of a science kid, maybe your kid doesn't fit in well in the structure of traditional public school. It's a great school. However, it's not scalable. It's a great option for those families and those kids, and I don't deny that.
很棒的学校。我有朋友送他们的孩子去那里。航空是你的背景，你的孩子有点科学头脑，也许你的孩子在传统公立学校的结构中不合适。这是一所很棒的学校。然而，它是不可扩展的。这对那些家庭和那些孩子来说是一个很好的选择，我不否认这一点。
But again, I'm looking at the bigger issue of if we create these little microcosms, and then eventually bring vouchers with it, we are still going to be crumbling our infrastructure, which still is going to serve the vast majority of children, because frankly, there's not enough little schools like that to serve the kids.
但再一次，我正在考虑如果我们创造这些小微观世界，然后最终带来代金券，我们仍然会破坏我们的基础设施，这仍然会服务绝大多数孩子，因为坦率地说，没有足够的像那样的小学校来服务孩子。
The vast majority of children, 85%, that's how many in this country attend traditional public schools.
绝大多数孩子，85%，这就是这个国家有多少人参加传统公立学校。
We will help some kids, but I don't believe we're going to help most kids. I believe it will actually harm them in the long run.
我们会帮助一些孩子，但我不相信我们会帮助大多数孩子。我相信从长远来看，这实际上会伤害他们。
For almost the past 20 years, Betsy DeVos and her husband Dick, maybe more than anyone, have shaped education in Michigan by advocating for policies that increase choice. The results? Both traditional public schools and charter schools are doing worse academically.
在过去近20年里，贝特西·德沃斯和她的丈夫迪克，也许比任何人都多，通过倡导增加择校的政策塑造了密歇根州的教育。结果呢？传统公立学校和特许学校在学术上都表现得更差。
To give one example, in 2003, Michigan fourth graders ranked 28th in the country in reading. A decade later, they've fallen to 41st. For all the promises about charter school performance, three quarters of all Michigan charter schools are in the bottom half of all schools as measured by standardized tests. Public school funding, the money actually available for schools to use, has declined.
举个例子，2003年，密歇根州四年级学生在阅读方面排名全国第28位。十年后，他们下降到了第41位。对于关于特许学校表现的所有承诺，四分之三的密歇根特许学校在标准化考试衡量中处于所有学校的后半部分。公立学校资金，实际可供学校使用的资金，已经减少了。
Segregation has increased. Under Michigan choice policies, white students transfer to districts or charters that are more white, black students go to charters that are more black. Meanwhile, a staggering number of Michigan charters are for profit, 80% according to researchers at Western Michigan University. Way more than any other state.
隔离增加了。根据密歇根州的择校政策，白人学生转移到更白人的学区或特许学校，黑人学生去更黑人的特许学校。与此同时，密歇根州惊人数量的特许学校是以营利为目的的，根据西密歇根大学的研究人员统计，有80%。比任何其他州都要多得多。
I have read that 80% of charter schools in Michigan are run by for-profit entities, and most of them perform below the state average.
我读到密歇根州80%的特许学校由营利性实体运营，而且大多数表现低于州平均水平。
At Betsy DeVos's confirmation hearing in January, Senator Sheldon Whitehouse asked her to respond to concerns about her record in Michigan.
在1月份贝特西·德沃斯的确认听证会上，参议员谢尔顿·怀特豪斯要求她回应关于她在密歇根州记录的担忧。
I will be an advocate for all great schools, no matter their form, their version. I will be an advocate for parents being able to make those choices because they're the primary educator for their children.
我将成为所有优秀学校的倡导者，无论其形式、版本如何。我将成为家长能够做出这些选择的倡导者，因为他们是孩子的主要教育者。
I get that. But the question is, do you understand that when the parent makes that choice, and the child moves to the charter school, and the funding moves with the child, that leaves a funding gap at the previous school that it can't instantaneously or magically fill, that that is a real problem that [INAUDIBLE] respect--
我明白了。但问题是，你明白吗，当家长做出那个选择，孩子转到特许学校，资金随着孩子流动时，这在之前的学校留下了一个资金缺口，它无法瞬间或奇迹般地填补，这是一个真正的问题，那个——
Indeed. And I mean, I think this is a good example of an issue that is best addressed at the state level. Again, I will--
确实。我的意思是，我认为这是一个最好在州层面解决的问题的好例子。再一次，我将——
They went back and forth but this was as much of an answer as she gave. But what public education advocates criticize Betsy DeVos for-- focusing more on the individual than the whole public school system-- DeVos welcomes that criticism. It's not a criticism to her. She says that's exactly what she's trying to do.
他们来回讨论，但这就像她给出的答案一样。但公立教育倡导者批评贝特西·德沃斯的地方——更多地关注个人而不是整个公立学校体系——德沃斯欢迎这种批评。这对她来说不是批评。她说这就是她试图做的事情。
This isn't about school systems. This is about individual students, parents, and families.
这不是关于学校系统。这是关于个别学生、家长和家庭。
Betsy DeVos, speaking in July at the ALEC Conference. ALEC is a national group for conservatives who want to privatize all kinds of government services, including schools. Betsy DeVos is standing behind a lectern in a bright pink skirt suit.
贝特西·德沃斯，7月在ALEC会议上发言。ALEC是一个全国性的保守派团体，他们希望私有化各种政府服务，包括学校。贝特西·德沃斯站在讲台后，穿着粉红色的短裙套装。
Just the other week, the American Federation for Teachers tweeted at me. Can you please put it up on the screen?
就在前几天，美国教师联合会给我发了推文。你能把它放到屏幕上吗？
The tweet reads, quote, "Betsy DeVos says public dollars should invest in individual students. No. We should invest in a system of great public schools for all kids."
推文写道，引述，“贝特西·德沃斯说公共资金应该投资于个别学生。不。我们应该为所有孩子投资一个伟大的公立学校体系。”
I couldn't believe it when I read it, but you have to admire their candor. They've made it clear that they care more about a system, one that was created in the 1800s, than they care about individual students. They are saying education is not an investment in individual students, and they are totally wrong.
我读到它时简直不敢相信，但你必须钦佩他们的坦率。他们已经明确表示，他们更关心一个系统，一个在1800年代创建的系统，而不是关心个别学生。他们是在说教育不是对个别学生的投资，他们完全错了。
[APPLAUSE]
（掌声）
This isn't just semantics. This is right at the heart of Betsy DeVos's argument. The way to improve education is to focus on each individual child. She and her backers say the system is broken. We've tried to fix it for years, and it hasn't worked. The most vulnerable kids are trapped in the worst schools. We have got to address this. We need to try something new.
这不仅仅是语义问题。这正是贝特西·德沃斯论点的核心。改善教育的方法是关注每一个孩子。她和她的支持者说系统坏了。我们多年来一直试图修复它，但它没有奏效。最脆弱的孩子被困在最糟糕的学校里。我们必须解决这个问题。我们需要尝试一些新的东西。
One of the reasons Betsy DeVos might believe in focusing on the individual student is that she's seen it work herself with some of the students she's helped.
贝特西·德沃斯可能相信关注个别学生的原因之一是，她已经看到它在她帮助过的一些学生身上发挥了作用。
Take a moment and picture a child whom you have helped get a great education. For me, I picture Angie, a young girl I've mentored since the first grade who is now entering her senior year in high school.
花点时间想象一个你帮助获得良好教育的孩子。对我来说，我想象安吉，我从一年级就开始辅导的一个年轻女孩，现在正进入高中的最后一年。
My name is Angie. I'm 17 years old.
我的名字是安吉。我17岁。
Angie is the second student Betsy DeVos mentored at Burton Elementary. I visited her during summer vacation at her house in Grand Rapids. She'd just gotten home from work, and she was wearing bleached jeans, her hair in a bun.
安吉是贝特西·德沃斯在伯顿小学辅导的第二名学生。我在暑假期间拜访了她在大急流城的家。她刚下班回家，穿着漂白的牛仔裤，头发扎成发髻。
She remembers being pulled out of her classroom in first grade and told, you're going to have a mentor. She was shy around Betsy DeVos.
她记得在一年级时被拉出教室，被告知，你将有一位导师。她在贝特西·德沃斯面前很害羞。
I was shy. Like, she would have to like ask me over and over again to get things out. And even to this day, I still get kind of shy when I'm around her and talking to her. Like, I know I can talk to her about anything, and I know I can trust her for anything, but I still get shy.
我很害羞。就像，她必须反复问我才能让我说出来。即使到今天，当我和她在一起并与她交谈时，我仍然感到有点害羞。就像，我知道我可以和她谈论任何事情，我知道我可以信任她做任何事情，但我仍然感到害羞。
Betsy DeVos became close to Angie and her family right away. On Christmas, she came over with presents. She did stuff with them on weekends.
贝特西·德沃斯很快与安吉和她的家人变得亲近。圣诞节时，她带着礼物来了。她在周末和他们一起做事情。
First memory, the earliest memory I have a way of that, of doing something like that, is when she took me, my mom, and my oldest sister to a bookstore. And she helped my mom get a book so that she can learn English. She let me get-- I don't even know what books I got. But she let me and my sisters get books.
第一个记忆，我记得最早的记忆，就是当她带我和我的妈妈以及我最大的姐姐去书店的时候。她帮我的妈妈买了一本书，这样她就可以学习英语。她让我买——我甚至不知道我买了什么书。但她让我和我的姐妹们买了书。
So after that, she would really ask about my mom. And then if I ever told her anything, that she would help out my mom, and my mom just really like, looked up to her.
所以在那之后，她会真正问起我妈妈。如果我告诉她任何事情，她会帮助我的妈妈，我妈妈真的非常尊敬她。
Angie's mother grew up in the Dominican Republic and speaks mostly Spanish. Back then, she was working factory jobs. She was always on the night shift, keeping her away from Angie and her sister. She has a chronic illness, and when it flared up, she'd missed work. She kept getting fired, so the DeVoses hired her.
安吉的妈妈在多米尼加共和国长大，主要说西班牙语。那时，她在工厂工作。她总是上夜班，使她远离安吉和她的姐姐。她有慢性病，当它发作时，她会错过工作。她一直被解雇，所以德沃斯夫妇雇用了她。
Well, she's like the laundry person at all their houses. She's the one that does laundry for them, and that's it. Basically, she's been doing that ever since.
嗯，她就像他们所有房子的洗衣工。她是为他们洗衣服的人，就是这样。基本上，她从那时起就一直在做这件事。
Betsy DeVos's impulse was not to keep Angie and her family at a distance, an hour a week, meet the program requirements, do the minimum. Her impulse was to invite them into her life. John Booy is a close friend of Betsy DeVos, one of a handful of people she brought to her confirmation hearing.
贝特西·德沃斯的冲动不是让安吉和她的家人保持距离，每周一小时，满足项目要求，做最少的事情。她的冲动是邀请他们进入她的生活。约翰·布伊是贝特西·德沃斯的密友，是她带到确认听证会的少数几个人之一。
He runs the Potter's House, a private Christian school in Grand Rapids that enrolls a lot of low income kids. Over the years, Betsy DeVos has mentored students there, and John's seen her help out several families.
他经营Potter's House，这是大急流城的一所私立基督教学校，招收了许多低收入孩子。多年来，贝特西·德沃斯在那里辅导过学生，约翰看到她帮助过几个家庭。
Betsy would also involve herself in whatever other ways that they could partner with the family. Now, they don't believe in the kind of helping that hurts, or the kind of helping that keeps somebody just dependent on you. They're very much about work and responsibility. But it's done in a way that's not patronizing. It doesn't take your dignity away. It's just walking alongside, and how can, you know, together strategize to meet your goals?
贝特西也会以他们可以与家庭合作的任何其他方式参与其中。现在，他们不相信那种会伤害人的帮助，也不相信那种让某人依赖你的帮助。他们非常注重工作和责任。但这是一种不傲慢的方式。它不会剥夺你的尊严。它只是并肩行走，如何，你知道，共同制定战略来实现你的目标？
After two years, Betsy DeVos suggested to Angie's mother that Angie transfer out of Burton to the private Christian school that John Booy runs. At first Angie was not on board with the idea. She didn't want to leave her friends and the school she knew.
两年后，贝特西·德沃斯向安吉的妈妈建议，安吉从伯顿转学到约翰·布伊经营的私立基督教学校。起初安吉并不同意这个想法。她不想离开她的朋友和她熟悉的学校。
Oh, I cried. I remember it was the last day of my second grade, and I had just came home, and they said that I wasn't going back, and I cried. Like, I did not want to switch schools.
哦，我哭了。我记得那是我二年级的最后一天，我刚回家，他们说我不回去，我哭了。就像，我不想转学。
But when she got to Potter's House, she understood why her mother and Betsy DeVos had wanted her to go there. Angie loved reading, and with more attention, she progressed faster. The work was more challenging. You had to want to do well.
但当她到达Potter's House时，她明白了为什么她的妈妈和贝特西·德沃斯希望她去那里。安吉喜欢阅读，随着更多的关注，她进步得更快。工作更具挑战性。你必须想要做得好。
Betsy DeVos continued to mentor Angie. When she got to middle school, sometimes Betsy DeVos would take her out at lunchtime.
贝特西·德沃斯继续辅导安吉。当她上初中时，有时贝特西·德沃斯会在午餐时间带她出去。
A few times, we went to Biggby's downtown to get hot chocolate. So that was fun. It was nice. She always has nice cars. That was just like-- I was always like amazed, because it was always a different car, or sometimes even a driver.
几次，我们去了市中心的Biggby's喝热巧克力。所以这很有趣。很好。她总是有很好的车。那就像——我总是很惊讶，因为那总是一辆不同的车，或者有时甚至是一个司机。
As Angie got older, Betsy DeVos helped her choose a high school to go to, suggested tours of three different schools. None are traditional public schools. She ended up at a private Christian high school, which she loves. Betsy DeVos pays part of her tuition and her mother pays the other part. This summer, Angie's working with her mother for the DeVos family.
随着安吉长大，贝特西·德沃斯帮助她选择了一所高中，建议参观三所不同的学校。没有一个是传统公立学校。她最终进入了一所私立基督教高中，她很喜欢。贝特西·德沃斯支付她部分学费，她的妈妈支付另一部分。今年夏天，安吉和她的妈妈一起为德沃斯家族工作。
Oh, I'm cleaning. [LAUGHS] Yeah, that's all I do every summer since eighth grade. Clean.
哦，我在打扫卫生。（笑）是的，那是我从八年级开始每年夏天所做的唯一事情。打扫。
She likes working, making her own money. She vacuums, mops, smaller stuff too.
她喜欢工作，赚自己的钱。她用吸尘器，拖地，也做些更小的事情。
We're house detailers. We make sure everything looks nice and good, and there's no dust anywhere, that the beds are like, fixed up pretty, that the bathrooms, everything like that. Anything you do in a house, that's what we do.
我们是房屋清洁工。我们确保一切看起来整洁，没有灰尘，床铺整理得很好，浴室等一切都很好。你在房子里做的任何事，这就是我们做的。
One of the other kids the DeVos's mentored works with them. He lives in the neighborhood, and they give him rides home. They're down at the family's summer compound in Holland most days, a lake shore estate with a mansion filled with delicate objects.
德沃斯夫妇辅导的其他孩子之一和他们一起工作。他住在附近，他们带他回家。他们大多数时间都在荷兰的家庭夏季大院，一个湖畔庄园，里面有一座充满精致物品的豪宅。
Everything has to be a certain way in a certain position. So we take pictures of everything, so that if we ever have to move something, we know exactly how it goes, like exactly how it goes. So, yeah.
一切都必须在特定的位置以特定的方式放置。所以我们给所有东西拍照，这样如果我们需要移动某样东西，我们就知道它确切的位置，就像它确切的位置。所以，是的。
Wanda, Angie's mother, is out on the porch, giving Angie privacy while also remaining near. She comes inside to talk.
旺达，安吉的妈妈，在门廊上，给安吉隐私，同时也保持靠近。她走进屋里谈话。
How would your life and Angie's life be different if you hadn't met Betsy?
如果你没见过贝特西，你和安吉的生活会有什么不同？
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
（说西班牙语）
Basically, it's like, a very private, kind of very sentimental thing. But she feels like Miss Betsy is someone who after God, she feels like God actually put her in our lives at the perfect moment, because she just came in when things were just very wrong and very bad for our lives.
基本上，这就像是一件非常私人、非常感性的事情。但她觉得贝丝小姐是一个在上帝之后的人，她觉得上帝实际上把她放在我们的生活中是在完美的时刻，因为当事情对我们的生活非常错误和非常糟糕时，她就进来了。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
（说西班牙语）
As Wanda says this, she cups a hand over her heart.
当旺达这么说时，她用手托着心。
But she's very grateful for Miss Betsy and everything she's done, because she's somebody who, without even asking for anything in return, gave my mom a hand and has just been there to help us with whatever it is that we need every step of the way.
但她非常感谢贝丝小姐和她所做的一切，因为她是一个人，甚至没有要求任何回报，就给了我妈妈一只手，并且一直在那里帮助我们需要的一切，每一步。
Angie doesn't totally follow the news, doesn't totally trust it. But for while, she was seeing things online about Betsy DeVos that upset her.
安吉并不完全关注新闻，并不完全信任它。但有一段时间，她在网上看到关于贝特西·德沃斯的事情让她很难过。
It would just make me feel like, really, like, bad in a way. Because it's not how things actually are. I know the actual truth. Like, I have a really close relationship with her, so I know how things actually are. And it's just-- it's whatever. I mean, everybody's gonna think what they want to think.
这会让我感觉，真的很，很糟糕。因为事情不是那样的。我知道实际的真相。就像，我和她有非常亲密的关系，所以我知道事情到底是怎么样的。这就——随便吧。我的意思是，每个人都会想他们想想的事情。
Angie's quick to say that Betsy DeVos is good for this job, because she's passionate about education and helping kids, all kids, and making it easier for kids to choose. But when I ask her what Betsy DeVos should do in this job, she doesn't pretend to have studied up on policy. Then a moment later, she suggests something.
安吉很快说，贝特西·德沃斯很适合这份工作，因为她对教育和帮助孩子充满热情，所有的孩子，并使孩子们更容易选择。但当我问她贝特西·德沃斯应该在这份工作中做什么时，她没有假装研究过政策。片刻之后，她建议了一些事情。
OK. Something I think she should hopefully at least like look into is making public schools better. Because public schools, they're not bad. But like, there's just some public schools that just like, the teachers don't really care to help our students and stuff like that, and they just want to give the students an A. So I feel like if she would look more into public schools, and just making them better for any kind of student no matter where, then that would be a good thing.
好的。我想她至少应该看一看的事情是让公立学校变得更好。因为公立学校，它们并不坏。但是，就像，有些公立学校只是像，老师真的不在乎帮助我们的学生之类的，他们只是想给学生一个A。所以我感觉如果她能更多地关注公立学校，让它们对任何学生无论在哪里都变得更好，那将是一件好事。
Of course, that's basically the job description of the Secretary of Education, to oversee the country's public schools and make them better for any kind of student. And what's so different about Betsy DeVos is that she doesn't care whether schools are public or not. It doesn't matter what word comes before school, she likes to say-- public, private, charter, home, virtual, magnet, parochial. That's a radically different way to see this job. But seeing what she did in Michigan, not a huge surprise.
当然，这基本上就是教育部长的工作描述，监督国家的公立学校，让它们对任何学生都变得更好。贝特西·德沃斯的不同之处在于，她不在乎学校是否是公立的。她说，学校前面是什么词并不重要——公立、私立、特许、家庭、虚拟、磁力、教区。这是一种看待这份工作的截然不同的方式。但看看她在密歇根州所做的，并不令人吃惊。
Susan Burton, who's one of the producers of our program. Coming up, rumors about cartoon characters coming alive in real life. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
苏珊·伯顿，我们节目的制片人之一。接下来，关于卡通人物在现实生活中活过来的传言。那是在一分钟后从芝加哥公共广播电台，当我们的节目继续时。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, Private Geography, stories of the places that we're from and how those places make us. We've arrived at Act Two of our program, Act Two, Kids in the Hall. And by hall in this case, I mean the Kingdom Hall.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目，私人地理，关于我们来自的地方以及这些地方如何造就我们的故事。我们已经到达了我们节目的第二幕，第二幕，大厅里的孩子。在这情况下，大厅指的是王国聚会所。
Your cultural identity, somebody once said, is not a suitcase you can lose at the airport. And that's true even if you're trying to lose it. One of our producers, Neil Drumming, discovered that truth recently, when he read an email that somebody sent to the radio show.
有人曾经说，你的文化身份不是你可以丢在机场的手提箱。即使你试图丢失它，这也是事实。我们的一位制片人尼尔·德拉明最近发现了这个事实，当他阅读有人发给广播节目的电子邮件时。
I was raised as a Jehovah's Witness until the age of 17, when I left the faith of my own volition. There are roughly 1 million Jehovah's Witnesses spread across the United States, few enough that every time I come across a former one, an ex-JW, I can't help but feel like it's an opportunity to share some rare communal experience. Like, what happened to you, or what made you leave?
我被抚养成为耶和华见证人直到17岁，当时我自愿离开了信仰。在美国各地大约有100万耶和华见证人，数量少到每次我遇到一个前成员，前JW，我都不禁觉得这是一个分享一些罕见共同经历的机会。就像，你发生了什么，或者是什么让你离开了？
That's why when I read the email that Will McMillian sent to This American Life, I immediately wanted to talk to him, though his experience was different from mine, in that he was once a Witness and also gay.
这就是为什么当我阅读威尔·麦克米利安发给《美国生活》的电子邮件时，我立即想和他交谈，尽管他的经历和我不同，因为他曾经是一名见证人，也是同性恋。
Do you remember what the Jehovah's Witness Bible says about homosexuality?
你还记得耶和华见证人的圣经关于同性恋是怎么说的吗？
Like from the Scriptures?
就像从经文中？
Yeah.
是的。
I remember there's a-- I apologize for not being more-- like, a better memory on this, but I actually gave a talk about homosexuality once.
我记得有一个——我很抱歉没有——比如，更好的记忆，但我实际上有一次做过关于同性恋的演讲。
That's Will. And when he says he gave a talk, he's referring to these speeches Jehovah's Witnesses are required to regularly give each other based on Scripture during services at the Kingdom Hall, which is what they call their house of worship.
那是威尔。当他说他做过演讲时，他指的是耶和华见证人被要求定期根据圣经在服务期间互相发表的演讲，在王国聚会所，这就是他们称之为敬拜场所的地方。
In his email to the show, Will said that he'd been a practicing witness since he was a teenager. He's 37 now. He also wrote that since he was about 10, he knew he was gay. He kept that fact a secret for 20 years because Jehovah's Witnesses believe that sometime in the near future, when Jehovah God cleanses the earth and remakes it into the paradise that it once was, those who have not faithfully obeyed his word will be destroyed.
在给节目的电子邮件中，威尔说他从十几岁起就一直在实践见证人信仰。他现在37岁。他还写道，从大约10岁起，他就知道自己是同性恋。他把这个事实保密了20年，因为耶和华见证人相信，在不久的将来，当耶和华上帝净化地球并将其重新创造回曾经的天堂时，那些没有忠实遵守他的话的人将被毁灭。
And there's a scripture that talks about some of you were thieves, some of you were murderers, some of you were tax evaders, and some of you were men who lied with men. Kind of this laundry list of, these are sins that will get you killed.
有一段经文谈到有些人是小偷，有些人是谋杀犯，有些人是逃税者，有些人是与男人躺在一起的男人。就像这个会导致你被杀的罪行清单。
OK. You know where this is going. In his early 30's, Will's homosexuality was uncovered, and he was kicked out of the religion. Witnesses call it being disfellowshipped. Will wrote in his email to us that at the time he got the boot, he felt like his life had come to an end.
好的。你知道这是怎么回事。在他30多岁时，威尔的同性恋身份被揭露，他被逐出了宗教。见证人称之为被开除。威尔在给我们的电子邮件中写道，当他被踢出去时，他觉得他的生活已经结束了。
But as he and I emailed back and forth, the thing that really struck me about him was how torn he still seemed to be. Here he was, finally happily living as a gay man a half dozen years later. And yet even now, Will doesn't smoke, he doesn't do drugs, he won't accept a blood transfusion, all things that Jehovah's Witnesses say the Bible forbids. He's still clinging to the dictates of a religion that forced him to deny his identity for two decades.
但当他和我在电子邮件中来回交流时，真正让我对他印象深刻的是他似乎仍然是多么纠结。他现在终于在六年后幸福地过着同性恋生活了。然而即使现在，威尔也不抽烟，他不吸毒，他不接受输血，所有耶和华见证人说圣经禁止的事情。他仍然坚持一个强迫他否认自己身份二十年的宗教的命令。
"My spiritual beliefs remained the same after I was disfellowshipped and after I came out," he wrote. "You want to accept yourself for who you are while at the same time condemning yourself for it." Will wrote that when he's around other openly gay men, he feels like he has to hide his spiritual beliefs from them, like some sort of closeted disciple. And when he sees great tragedy in the world, like an earthquake, a school shooting, or a hate-filled attack on an Orlando nightclub, his mind goes immediately to prophecy that was drilled into him from an early age.
“我被开除后，我的精神信仰保持不变，在我出柜后，”他写道。“你想接受你是谁，同时又因为它是谁而谴责自己。”威尔写道，当他在其他公开的同性恋男人身边时，他觉得他必须对他们隐瞒他的精神信仰，就像某种秘密的门徒。当他在世界上看到巨大的悲剧时，比如地震、学校枪击或针对奥兰多夜总会的仇恨攻击，他的思绪立即转向他从小就被灌输的预言。
Quote, "I am seeing the signs. I need to be close to Jehovah. I need to stop being a pawn of Satan with my debauched life. I need to save myself from eternal destruction." All the stuff he used to believe.
引述，“我看到了迹象。我需要接近耶和华。我需要停止成为我放荡生活的撒旦的棋子。我需要拯救自己免于永恒的毁灭。”所有他曾经相信的东西。
I really believed it. I really believed what I was being taught, or what I was trying to teach other people. I really did believe that we're in the last days of this system of things, and I can watch and see rainforests get destroyed, or I can see politicians come in to office and do terrible things to people and think, it's OK, because Jehovah will take care of it, and all these things that are going wrong are only temporary.
我真的相信它。我真的相信我被教导的东西，或者我试图教导其他人的东西。我确实相信我们处于这个事物的最后日子，我可以观察并看着雨林被破坏，或者我可以看着政客们上台对人们做可怕的事情并想，没关系，因为耶和华会处理它，所有这些出错的事情都只是暂时的。
The last days, this system of things, Satan and his demons. It was both freaky and familiar to hear Will using all this ominous terminology I'd grown up with, but almost completely forgotten. When I read his emails, I knew that I wanted to talk to Will, but I wasn't exactly sure why until it happened. It just felt familiar. I wanted to revisit that.
最后日子，这个事物的系统，撒旦和他的恶魔。听到威尔使用我从小就成长并几乎完全忘记的所有这些不祥的术语，既令人毛骨悚然又熟悉。当我读他的电子邮件时，我知道我想和威尔交谈，但我并不完全确定为什么，直到它发生。它只是感觉熟悉。我想重温那个。
When you're a witness-- and maybe you'll remember this-- when you're told that anything supernatural is demonic, you kind of shut those things down.
当你是一个见证人——也许你会记得这个——当你被告知任何超自然的东西都是邪恶的，你会有点关闭这些东西。
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
是的，是的，是的。
At least I did. I shut those things down.
至少我做了。我关闭了那些东西。
Yeah. And I really loved fantasy novels. And I felt that I couldn't read them.
我有一个非常有身体暴力的父亲。我觉得我做的每一件事，或者我感兴趣的每一件事，我爸爸都讨厌。就像，你可以看出是否有人喜欢对你不友善。如果我想去外面，他会说不，你不能去外面，并且会在脸上带着微笑说。
Yeah, right?
是的，对吧？
Like, I felt like I shouldn't be reading them.
就像，我觉得我不应该读它们。
Exactly. Yeah, and I loved science fiction, and there was a period of time where I was writing a lot of science fiction, and I was like, kind of doing it secretively.
完全正确。是的，我喜欢科幻小说，有一段时间我写了很多科幻小说，我就像，有点偷偷摸摸地做。
Yeah, you know, when I was a kid, there was a rumor in the Hall. This is crazy.
是的，你知道，当我还是个孩子时，大厅里有一个传言。这太疯狂了。
The Smurf rumor?
蓝精灵传言？
The Smurf rumor. No, you heard the Smurf rumor? OK. Tell it to me. Tell it to me the way you heard it. I want to hear this.
蓝精灵传言。不，你听说过蓝精灵传言？好的。告诉我。以你听到的方式告诉我。我想听这个。
Oh, my gosh. As soon as you said you heard a rumor, I'm like, is it the Smurf rumor? Yes, the Smurf rumor, for everybody who doesn't know the Smurf rumor, apparently a sister came to the congregation with one of her children who had a Smurf doll, and during the meeting the Smurf doll came to life, and started running back and forth through the aisles saying, [BLEEP] you, [BLEEP] you, [BLEEP] God, [BLEEP] Jehovah, back and forth through the Kingdom Hall. Is that your version of it?
哦，天哪。当你刚说你听说过传言时，我就像，是蓝精灵传言吗？是的，蓝精灵传言，对于不知道蓝精灵传言的每个人，显然一个姐妹带着一个有蓝精灵娃娃的孩子来到聚会，在聚会期间蓝精灵娃娃活了过来，开始在过道之间跑来跑去说，（哔）你，（哔）你，（哔）上帝，（哔）耶和华，在王国聚会所之间跑来跑去。这是你的版本吗？
I feel like I'm about to cry. I've never heard this corroborated. You have more detail. The way I heard it was, a kid came to the Kingdom Hall with a Smurf in their back pocket, and it jumped out and ran out. But it's essentially the same idea, is that the mythology around the Smurfs were so demonic that they were, I don't know, somehow associated with Satan.
我觉得我快要哭了。我从来没有听到过这个被证实。你有更多细节。我听到的方式是，一个孩子带着一个蓝精灵在后口袋来到王国聚会所，它跳出来跑出去了。但这本质上是同样的想法，是关于蓝精灵的神话太邪恶了，以至于他们，我不知道，某种程度上与撒旦有关。
Repressed nerdiness is about where the similarities between Will and I end. I grew up in Queens. He's from the Pacific Northwest. I'm black. He's white. I'm straight. He's gay. And my mother raised me in the Truth, which is how Jehovah's Witnesses colloquially refer to their faith. No one in Will's immediate family was a practicing witness. He found the Truth and chose it for himself, although family has a lot to do with why he did.
压抑的极客感大约是威尔和我之间相似之处结束的地方。我在皇后区长大。他来自太平洋西北地区。我是黑人。他是白人。我是异性恋。他是同性恋。我的母亲在真理中抚养我，这是耶和华见证人口语中指代他们信仰的方式。威尔直系亲属中没有实践见证人。他发现了真理并为自己选择了它，尽管家庭与他为什么这样做有很大关系。
I had a very physically violent father. Everything that I felt like I did or that I was interested, my dad hated. Like, you could tell if somebody is enjoying being unkind to you. If I wanted to go outside, he'd say no, you can't go outside, and would say with a smile on his face.
我的父亲有很严重的暴力倾向。我所做的一切或者我感兴趣的事情，他都非常讨厌。那种感觉就像是，你能看出一个人是否在以虐待你为乐。如果我想出去玩，他会拒绝，说我不可以出去，而且还会脸上挂着笑对我说。
When Will was about 11 years old, his family moved into a new place, and he met the Planks. The Planks were a neighboring family of Jehovah's Witnesses, a mom, a dad, and two daughters. As soon as he started going over to their house, Will notice something different about them.
当威尔大约11岁时，他的家人搬到了一个新的地方，他遇到了Planks一家。Planks一家是邻居耶和华见证人家庭，一位妈妈，一位爸爸，和两个女儿。当他开始去他们家时，威尔注意到他们身上有些不同。
Oh, these are people who are nice, and they really seem to love each other, and they really seem to be close to each other. And so it was just a complete diametric opposite of what I was experiencing right next door in my own home. I felt that I could kind of be a little more silly, that I could be a little more calm.
哦，这些人很友好，他们似乎真的很爱对方，他们似乎真的很亲近。所以这完全是和我隔壁家里体验到的完全相反。我觉得我可以有点更傻一点，我可以有点更冷静一点。
And I associated how they behaved with them being Jehovah's Witnesses, because they would always say things like, Jehovah provides, or we do these things and Jehovah blessed us. And so it was really like, oh, so there's a reason why you're like this.
我把他们的行为方式与他们是耶和华见证人联系起来，因为他们总是会说像，耶和华提供，或者我们做这些事情，耶和华保佑我们。所以这真的就像，哦，所以这就是为什么你是这样的原因。
So Will began studying with the Planks, learning Scripture and lessons from the parents right alongside their daughters. He did so in secret. He didn't tell his family that he was becoming a Jehovah's Witness. It was his escape.
所以威尔开始和Planks一家一起学习，学习圣经和父母的课程，和他们的女儿一起。他秘密地做了。他没有告诉他的家人他正在成为一名耶和华见证人。这是他的逃避。
It was almost like a form of a very kind of sweet rebellion in a way, where it's like having a clubhouse that nobody has access to but me.
这几乎就像一种非常甜蜜的叛逆，就像拥有一个除了我之外没有人能进入的俱乐部。
At the Planks's and eventually at the Kingdom Hall, Will found kindness, acceptance, and engagement amongst the brothers and sisters there. And for him, there was a special added bonus.
在Planks一家，最终在王国聚会所，威尔在兄弟姐妹中找到了仁慈、接受和参与。对他来说，有一个特别的额外奖励。
When I realized that I was gay, I saw it as an imperfection in myself, like if I thought that I was a kleptomaniac. Like, OK, jeez, I've got this huge thing about myself that I need to figure out how to control, and I need to learn how to hate. And so being a Witness was to me like the most strict form of control that I could do.
当我意识到我是同性恋时，我把它看作是我自己的不完美，就像如果我觉得我是盗窃狂一样。就像，好的，天哪，关于我自己我有这件大事，我需要弄清楚如何控制，我需要学会如何恨。所以作为一个见证人，对我来说就像我可以做的最严格的控制形式。
Exercising that control wasn't easy for Will. The Bible says plenty about temptation, none of which I can specifically remember, the upshot of which is that temptation is everywhere.
锻炼那种控制对威尔来说并不容易。圣经关于诱惑说了很多，我不记得具体的，结果是诱惑无处不在。
I loved the show Will and Grace, but I'm like, I cannot watch this show because Satan is watching me.
我喜欢威尔和格蕾丝的节目，但我说，我不能看这个节目，因为撒旦在看着我。
Did you have crushes within the Kingdom Hall?
你在王国聚会所里有暗恋的人吗？
Are you kidding?
你在开玩笑吗？
It's a lot of men in suits.
有很多穿西装的人。
There's a lot of suits, yeah, and that are good speakers. I loved to give talks. I loved to write talks. It was smooth. I was very, very good. And it came very easily for me to do. And so when I would have a brother compliment me, getting male praise was kind of intoxicating. And it was-- I would say like, when I got baptized when I was 23 was really when I really began to feel sort of my depression because I was really trying to do more and more in the congregation to suppress that feeling of being gay.
有很多西装，是的，他们是很好的演讲者。我喜欢演讲。我喜欢写演讲稿。很顺利。我非常、非常好。做起来对我来说很容易。所以当我有兄弟称赞我时，得到男性的称赞有点让人陶醉。这——我会说，当我23岁受洗时，我才真正开始感到某种忧郁，因为我真的试图在聚会中做更多的事情来抑制那种同性恋的感觉。
Meanwhile, there were would be brothers that I would have crushes on, and they'd be married. I would be developing these relationships, these friendships, with these brothers, and I would start to get feelings for, and would we get irritated because I can't do anything about this. I found myself getting more and more needy around these brothers because I would want to like, so do you want to come over hang out? Do you want to go do something? Do you want to go for a hike? Do you want to go do this? And they'd be like, let me check with my wife. And I would just be like, ugh, fine.
与此同时，会有我暗恋的兄弟，他们结婚了。我会发展这些关系，这些友谊，与这些兄弟，我会开始对他们产生感情，我会因为我不能对这个做任何事而感到烦躁。我发现自己对这些兄弟越来越依赖，因为我想，你想要过来玩吗？你想要去做点什么吗？你想要去徒步旅行吗？你想要去做这个吗？他们会说，让我和我的妻子检查一下。我就会像，呃，好吧。
Will persisted for years fighting his natural inclinations and growing more and more active in the truth. By the time he was 30, he was what witnesses call a full-time pioneer, putting in 70 hours worth of street preaching and evangelical work per month, living with a cousin and her family who were Jehovah's Witnesses.
威尔坚持多年，与他的自然倾向作斗争，在真理中变得越来越活跃。到他30岁时，他是见证人所称的全职先驱，每月花费70小时的街头布道和传福音工作，与一个耶和华见证人的堂兄弟和她的家人住在一起。
And I was in my 30's and now a virgin still, and your sexuality doesn't really go anywhere. To be blunt, I needed an outlet. And I knew I wasn't interested in girls. And so I would go to gay websites, graphic gay websites.
我30多岁了，仍然是处女，你的性倾向真的不会去任何地方。直接说，我需要一个出口。我知道我对女孩不感兴趣。所以我会上同性恋网站，图形化的同性恋网站。
When you would visit those websites, that is appealing to a thing that is intrinsically you. So was there any relief to actually acknowledging yourself, to like acknowledging who you were? Was that-- did you get even like, a small amount of like satisfaction from that?
当你访问这些网站时，那是在吸引本质上是你的一件事。所以承认自己，承认你是谁有任何解脱吗？那——你甚至从那得到了一点点满足感吗？
No. I felt nothing but guilt.
不。除了内疚我什么都没感觉到。
Will was out picking up Chinese food for the rest of the family when they discovered his browser history. The cousin's eldest son, a college student, was trying to figure out why internet service was slow in the house that night. He thought maybe Will had left his laptop downloading some big file or another. When Will got back with dinner, the husband confronted him at the door.
威尔出去为家人买中餐时，他们发现了他的浏览记录。堂兄弟的长子，一名大学生，试图找出那天晚上家里的互联网服务为什么慢。他以为威尔可能把他的笔记本电脑留下下载了一些大文件。当威尔带着晚餐回来时，丈夫在门口与他对质。
It was like having my skin ripped off of me at that moment. And I just started lying.
那一刻就像我的皮被从我身上撕下来。我开始撒谎。
Wow. What did you say?
哇。你说了什么？
I was like, you know what? My computer has malware on it, and it keeps bringing up all these pornography websites. And I keep trying to minimize it and get rid of it, but it's not me. And I kept saying like, you know me. You know I wouldn't do this. This is a huge mistake. And so he like, pulled open my laptop and was like, well, this isn't just something from a few weeks or a few months. He goes, this goes back years.
我说，你知道吗？我的电脑上有恶意软件，它一直弹出所有这些色情网站。我一直试图最小化它并摆脱它，但这不是我。我一直说，你知道我。你知道我不会做这个。这是一个巨大的错误。所以他打开我的笔记本电脑说，嗯，这不仅仅是几周或几个月的东西。他说，这可以追溯到几年。
There's no defiance there. There's no anger.
那里没有反抗。没有愤怒。
No. That he checked my computer and saw that?
不。他检查了我的电脑并看到了那个？
Yeah, and that like-- you know, I'm projecting because I'm listening to this story, and I'm angry. I feel angry for you. You know, I'm just like, the whole notion that you would say like, you know me, I wouldn't do this. It's like, he doesn't know you at all.
是的，那就像——你知道，我是在投射，因为我在听这个故事，我很生气。我为你感到生气。你知道，我只是觉得，你会说你知道我，我不会做这个的想法。就像，他根本不了解你。
The husband told him to pack up his things and drove him to a hotel. News of Will's transgression soon spread through the Kingdom Hall. He was brought before a judicial committee of congregation elders.
丈夫告诉他收拾行李并把他开车送到一家酒店。威尔越轨的消息很快传遍了王国聚会所。他被带到了一个由聚会长老组成的司法委员会面前。
They said a prayer. And they said, so tell us why you're here? Tell us tell us what you've done. And once I made the confession, one of the brothers pulled out this piece of paper, and there was a bunch of questions. But the first question was, are you attracted to minors? Have you ever had sex with a minor? Are you attracted to animals? Have you ever engaged in bestiality?
他们做了祈祷。他们说，所以告诉我们你为什么在这里？告诉我们告诉我们你做了什么。一旦我坦白，其中一个兄弟拿出这张纸，上面有一堆问题。但第一个问题是，你对未成年人有吸引力吗？你曾经和未成年人发生过性关系吗？你对动物有吸引力吗？你曾经参与过兽交吗？
Those are the first questions they asked you?
那是他们问你的第一个问题？
First four questions that they asked me.
他们问我的前四个问题。
He was stripped of his privileges within the Kingdom Hall and essentially put on probation, where he could attend meetings in silence, but little else. On top of that, he was informed that no matter what happened, he would never be allowed to be alone with children in the congregation ever again. Will quietly accept this reprobation without resistance.
他被剥夺了王国聚会所内的特权，基本上处于缓刑，在那里他可以静静地参加聚会，但几乎没有其他事情。最重要的是，他被告知，无论发生什么，他永远不会再被允许单独与聚会中的孩子在一起。威尔默默地接受了这种责备而没有抵抗。
The next phase in Will's life began the way so many new beginnings do these days, with the dating app OKCupid. Instead of starting back to the Hall immediately, Will decided he needed some time to himself and moved in with a friend of his, a non-Witness. She had just opened up her own OKCupid profile.
威尔生活的下一阶段以如今这么多新开始的方式开始了，使用约会应用程序OKCupid。威尔没有立即回到大厅，他决定他需要一点时间给自己，并和一个朋友住在一起，一个非见证人。她刚刚开通了自己的OKCupid资料。
And she was like you should make one too. And I was like, OK. And so I made one, and I made it like, man seeking woman, just to see what would happen. That alone was something I shouldn't have been doing, because if you're a brother, you only date sisters. You only date within your religion.
她是说你也应该做一个。我是说，好的。所以我做了一个，我把它做成，男人寻找女人，看看会发生什么。仅这一点就是我不应该做的事情，因为如果你是兄弟，你只和姐妹约会。你只在你的宗教内约会。
But again, I was like, I'm just taking a vacation from all of that stress. I'm just going to see what this feels like. And for a couple of weeks, it was, you know, man seeking woman. And then I thought, what if I changed it to man seeking man? Like, I remember like, kind of my finger on the mouse changing the designation from seeking female to male, and I was shaking, and I'm like, am I really going to do this? And I was daring myself to do it. And I did it.
但再一次，我是说，我只是在从所有这些压力中休假。我只是想看看这是什么感觉。几周来，这是，你知道，男人寻找女人。然后我想，如果我把它改成男人寻找男人会怎样？就像，我记得就像，某种程度上我的手指在鼠标上将指定从寻找女性改为男性，我正在颤抖，我想，我真的要这样做吗？我在挑战自己去做。我做了。
Will made plans for lunch in downtown Portland with a younger guy named Jason.
威尔在波特兰市中心和一名叫杰森的年轻人计划吃午餐。
And so we met up at the sandwich shop, and he was gay.
所以我们在三明治店见面，他是同性恋。
[LAUGHS]
（笑）
And he was gay. And because I mean--
他是同性恋。因为我是指——
What does that mean?
那是什么意思？
It doesn't mean anything bad. It just means like-- because it wasn't bad. Because we were talking, and he was like, he's been out since he was like, 16 or 17 years old. And I think he was like 25, 26 at the time. Maybe a little older. But he was absolutely comfortable with himself. He was absolutely assured of himself.
这不意味着任何坏事。这只是意味着就像——因为它并不坏。因为我们在谈话，他就像，他自从16或17岁起就出柜了。我想他当时大约25、26岁。也许大一点。但他对自己绝对舒服。他绝对对自己有信心。
Will and Jason dated for a couple of months before they had sex. It was a huge step for Will. But when it was over, Will didn't feel the way he thought he would.
威尔和杰森约会了几个月才发生性关系。这对威尔来说是一大步。但结束后，威尔并没有感到他以为他会有的感觉。
That sense of devastation that I was like, oh, my gosh I've completely severed my relationship with God didn't happen.
那种我想，哦，天哪，我完全切断了我与上帝的关系的毁灭感并没有发生。
It didn't happen.
它没有发生。
It didn't happen. No, which was equally weird. I'm like, oh. Here I was thinking I was going to be completely destroyed. And--
它没有发生。不，这同样奇怪。我是说，哦。我在这里以为我会完全被摧毁。而——
It's like you're waiting for the lightning bolt.
这就像你在等待闪电。
Yeah, and it never-- it didn't drop on me. But I mean, I still felt kind of weird. Like, I remember feeling like, well, you've done it now. There is no going back from this experience. You're going to have to tell the brothers that you did this.
是的，它从来没有——它没有掉在我身上。但我的意思是，我仍然感觉有点奇怪。就像，我记得感觉就像，好吧，你现在已经做了。这次经历没有回头路了。你必须告诉兄弟你做了这个。
And he was right. As crazy as this sounds, the very morning after he lost his virginity, Will came home to an email from another witness, an old friend, who had somehow stumbled upon Will's OKCupid profile and was now threatening to out him. I mentioned to Will that it seemed to me rather suspicious that this righteous and straight and happily married brother just happened to have discovered Will's men seeking men profile.
他是对的。尽管这听起来很疯狂，就在他失去处女身的第二天早上，威尔回家收到另一位见证人，一位老朋友的电子邮件，他不知何故偶然发现了威尔的OKCupid资料，现在正在威胁要出柜他。我向威尔提到，在我看来，那位正义、正直且婚姻幸福的兄弟碰巧发现了威尔的男人寻找男人资料，这相当可疑。
But Will, good-natured as he is, refused to go down that speculative road with me. He said the brother wrote, either you tell them or I will. And so with the proverbial gun to his head, Will called up one of the elders and told him that he had, as he put it then, a problem. He was kicked out, officially disfellowshipped.
但威尔，像他一样善良，拒绝和我走那条投机之路。他说兄弟写道，要么你告诉他们，要么我会。所以带着谚语中指着他头的枪，威尔打电话给其中一位长老，告诉他他当时称之为，一个问题。他被踢了出去，正式被开除。
Unlike Will, I was never disfellowshipped. When I was 16 or 17, I gave my mom this long handwritten letter informing her that I had stopped believing in God and that I no longer wanted to be one of Jehovah's Witnesses. I don't remember exactly what was in the letter. I'm sure I didn't mention that hormones and a sudden vexing need to talk to girls were factors in my decision.
和威尔不同，我从来没有被开除。当我是16或17岁时，我给了我妈妈这封长长的手写信，告知她我已经停止相信上帝，我不再想成为耶和华见证人之一。我不记得信里到底写了什么。我肯定没有提到荷尔蒙和突然困扰我与女孩交谈的需求是我决定中的因素。
Anyway, I slammed that door really hard, and it became one of the defining choices of my life. Shortly after I gave Ma the letter, I flew 3,000 miles away to college, and by the time I stepped off the plane, I was an atheist. For the most part, I'm relatively proud of everything I've become after that.
无论如何，我狠狠地关上了那扇门，这成为我一生中定义的选择之一。在我给妈那封信后不久，我就飞了3000英里去上大学，当我走下飞机时，我是一个无神论者。在很大程度上，我对他之后成为的一切相对自豪。
When I first read Will's email, I couldn't understand why he was holding onto the truth. The Jehovah's Witnesses had publicly slammed the door on who he was and who he was becoming. It wasn't that I thought he should be angry, although I felt like he should be a little angry. But I wondered why he wasn't free, why he sometimes still thought that Harry Potter was satanic, or that his sexuality was a sin, or why he couldn't just move on.
当我第一次读威尔的电子邮件时，我不明白为什么他坚持真理。耶和华见证人公开关上了他是谁以及他正在成为谁的门。并不是我觉得他应该生气，虽然我觉得他应该有一点生气。但我很好奇为什么他没有自由，为什么他有时仍然认为哈利波特是撒旦的，或者他的性倾向是一种罪，或者为什么他不能继续前进。
After talking to Will for a while, it became obvious that it's just not that easy. He was a witness for a long time. What he learned won't just go away. And then something more surprising hit me, a pang of envy. I was a little jealous of the way Will remembered specific scriptures, even the ones that condemned him.
在和威尔谈了一会儿后，很明显这并不容易。他很长一段时间都是见证人。他所学到的东西不会消失。然后更令人惊讶的事情打动了我，一阵嫉妒。我有点嫉妒威尔记得特定经文的方式，即使是那些谴责他的经文。
Were you around for the Knowledge book?
你参与了《知识》书吗？
Was that the red one?
那是红色的那个吗？
No, I think that that's the Live Forever book maybe.
不，我想那是《永生》书也许。
Oh, yeah, yeah. It sounds familiar, but I don't remember which one it was.
哦，是的，是的。它听起来很熟悉，但我记不起来是哪一本。
The Knowledge that Leads to Everlasting Life. I remember I was reading out of that book when I was a teenager, and I loved it.
《引向永生的知识》。我记得当我十几岁时，我读那本书，我喜欢它。
Will recalled the details, what the different Jehovah's Witness books were called and their corresponding colors, the meetings, the designations of all the elders. I had made turning my back on the truth such a significant part of my identity that I had lost these memories.
威尔回忆起细节，不同的耶和华见证人书叫什么以及它们相应的颜色，聚会，所有长老的指定。我把我背对真理变成了我身份中如此重要的一部分，以至于我失去了这些记忆。
I'm sorry, can we nerd out on Jehovah's Witnesses just a little bit, just a little bit. One thing.
对不起，我们可以稍微对耶和华见证人极客一下，就一点点。一件事。
Sure. Yeah, totally.
当然。是的，完全。
I have heard that nowadays, that you don't have to necessarily analyze Scripture anymore. You just have to read it.
我听说如今，你不一定要再分析圣经了。你只需要读它。
I was there for that transition.
我当时就在那里经历了那个过渡。
Oh, OK.
哦，好的。
Yeah, so then these yahoos are getting up to read through a couple of passages, and I'm just like, man, in my day--
是的，所以这些混蛋正在起来读过几段段落，我只是像，伙计，在我的日子——
Yeah, back in my day, we had to like, actually know what the Scripture meant.
是的，在我那个年代，我们不得不像，实际知道经文是什么意思。
I should say in recent years, Jehovah's Witnesses reorganized their meetings again to focus more on understanding and interpreting Scripture. I don't remember half of what I learned in the Kingdom Hall, but there is enough that has stuck with me that still occasionally affects the way I see the world or the decisions I make, even if I don't like to admit it. Will calls it a spiritual aftertaste.
我应该说近年来，耶和华见证人再次重组了他们的聚会，以更多地关注理解和解释圣经。我不记得我在王国聚会所学到的一半东西，但已经有一些留在了我身上，即使我不喜欢承认，有时也会影响我看待世界的方式或我做出的决定。威尔称之为精神余味。
Just this morning I had like, something that I really, really, really wanted to happen, and I was hoping it would happen. And I had a gut feeling of, what can I do about this? And the word "pray" came to mind, which is ridiculous for me. I've haven't prayed since I was 17 years old. And it's like, I don't believe in the power of prayer. But it's like built into your DNA at a certain point, or like, you know, more into your muscle memory. And it just-- it made me actually angry to feel that way because I try to be self-determined.
就在今天早上我有像，一些我真的、真的、真的想要发生的事情，我希望它能发生。我有一种直觉，关于这件事我能做什么？单词祈祷浮现在脑海，这对我来说很可笑。我自从17岁起就没祈祷过。就像，我不相信祈祷的力量。但它就像在某一点构建在你的DNA中，或者像，你知道，更多进入你的肌肉记忆。它只是——这让我感到真正愤怒，有这种感觉，因为我试着自决。
Yeah. It's almost like, I think if you think of in terms of military training, you kind of react to situations based on what your training has told you.
是的。这几乎就像，我想如果你认为在军事训练方面，你有点根据你的训练告诉你的情况作出反应。
After I quit, my mom sent me a few long handwritten letters urging me to come back to the Kingdom Hall. At least, I think that's what they said. I never read any of them. I felt like I had made my decision, and I hated that she questioned it. These days, when I see Jehovah's Witnesses in the street handing out material, I sometimes go rigid and quickly look away. I just don't want to deal with it. I picked a side.
在我退出后，我的妈妈寄给我几封长长的手写信，敦促我回到王国聚会所。至少，我想这就是他们说的。我从没读过其中任何一封。我觉得我已经做了我的决定，我讨厌她质疑它。如今，当我看到耶和华见证人在街上分发材料时，我有时会变得僵硬并迅速移开目光。我只是不想处理它。我选了一边。
But Will stands halfway between them and me. He's half in and half out. Somehow, that made it possible to look back for a couple of hours, to remember that it meant something to me then without it having to mean something to me now.
但威尔站在他们和我之间。他一半在里面，一半在外面。不知何故，这使它有可能回头看几个小时，记得它对当时的我意味着什么，而不需要它对现在的我意味着什么。
Neil Drumming is one of the produces of our show.
尼尔·德拉明是我们节目的制作人之一。
Our program was produced today by Dana Chivvis. Our staff includes Elna Baker, Susan Burton, Ben Calhoun, Zoe Chace, Sean Cole, Whitney Dangerfield, Neil Drumming, Stephanie Foo, Kimberly Henderson, Chana Joffe-Walt, David Kestenbaum, Seth Lind, Miki Meek, Robyn Semien, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, Julie Whitaker, and Diane Wu. Our senior producer is Brian Reed.
我们的节目今天由达娜·奇维斯制作。我们的员工包括埃尔纳·贝克、苏珊·伯顿、本·卡尔霍恩、佐伊·蔡斯、肖恩·科尔、惠特尼·丹格菲尔德、尼尔·德拉明、斯蒂芬妮·傅、金伯利·亨德森、查纳·乔夫-沃尔特、大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆、塞思·林德、米基·米克、罗宾·塞米恩、克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉、马特·蒂尔尼、朱莉·惠特克和黛安·吴。我们的资深制作人是布莱恩·里德。
[ACKNOWLEDGMENTS]
（致谢）
Gerald Murnane, the Austrian novelist I talked to at the beginning of the show, he's the author of The Plains and other books. He has not one, but two books coming out here in the States soon. One is Border Districts. The other Stream System-- The Collected Short Fiction of Gerald Murnane.
杰拉德·莫南，我在节目开始时谈到的奥地利小说家，他是《平原》和其他书的作者。他很快就要在美国出不少于两本书。一本是《边界区域》。另一本是《流系统——杰拉德·莫南短篇小说集》。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks as always to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, he's still wearing those special glasses that he bought to watch the eclipse. He says they are so powerful.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由PRX，公共广播交易所分发给公共广播电台。像往常一样感谢我们节目的联合创始人，托雷·马拉蒂亚先生。你知道，他仍然戴着他买来看日食的那副特殊眼镜。他说它们太强大了。
And I can watch and see rainforests get destroyed, or I can see politicians come into office and do terrible things to people.
我可以观察并看着雨林被破坏，或者我可以看着政客们上台对人们做可怕的事情。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。